hello everyone just 24 tweeted about
this game and I couldn't resist not
doing a video on it as its played
between a husband and wife in round one
of a tournament held in Armenia it's
called the saga the sagas door open I
don't know if I pronounced that
correctly but before I show you the game
I would like to think three steps move -
Felix cannot sir and I'm a Pirates for a
contribution to my channel thanks a lot
I really appreciate it as I forgot to
update my interface in the previous
video so that being said the game is
played between Alexander Hilario Takeda
Sakai dos Santos fear and that certainly
does sound like royalty but he's a he's
a Brazilian with a German Japanese
descent so I guess it's a mixture of all
of these and he's his quite a strong
player he's right at around 25 50 in
2005 he won the Brazilian chess
championship he won a lot of junior
championships when he was younger he
participated in the World Cup four times
in the in 2011 he won in the first round
but got eliminated in the second round
by Alexander Milosevic and in 2013 he
defeated Ladislav Wojcik in round one
you all know the grater addict but he
got eliminated by Bhaskar inaudible in
round 2 and I always want to mention
this but I always forget I really
started liking Bhaskar inaudible from
that Tata Steel tournament in January
when he played against Wesley so with
the white pieces and the game started e4
e5 and the Bhaskar inaudible played f4
the Kings gambit and I was like that's
that's how we play chess I mean Kings
gambit against the 2800 player that's
that's that's what I like and the game
ended in a draw but it was a very
exciting nonetheless so I will
definitely have to do a video or two
about mascara not ebon but getting back
to the game
Alexander is playing against his wife
and you know mice rats and Nina is a
Georgian chaste woman Grandmaster and
she's also two times women's a French
champion and well it's a very
interesting game because it features the
bird opening
so let's see this game we have f4 by
Nino and E 5 this is the the standard
frome's gambit F captures on d5 d6 you
capture the second-born accepting it
captures on d6 now Bishop captures on d6
and the knight to f3 and here we have g5
the Lasker variation of the birds
opening g3 g4 kicking the knight Knight
to h4 and we have 9th to e7 d4 Knight
goes to g6 now Knight captures H
captures now the rook has an open H file
and it's pretty obvious that that Nina
will not Castle kingside in this game
Queen to d3 and immediately Bishop to f5
Alexander is very aggressive
efore now and Queen to e7 pinning d4
pawn bishop to g2 defending the pawn and
now Knight to c6 Queen to e3 unpinning
from the bishop and also preparing maybe
to push me 5 in some variations Bishop
back to d7 we have a bishop to d2 and
rook to h5 now
the rook is entering the game Knight to
c3 Knight the b4 now with ideas of
capturing and c2 if you know blunders
and also pushing c5 we have a queen size
castle and c5 now and okay it seems like
black does have some contra play here
but what is definitely better 'if I've
now Bishop to c7 and now Knights the e4
good ideas of Knight to f6 forking the
king and the rook on h5 and here we have
a it's it's hard to say what is what is
blacks best move here nothing nothing
really seems to work in this position
Alexandra played seek address on d4 and
okay this does have a tempo on the Queen
but the problem is this loses the game
instantly after Queen to b3 which was
played in the game now Nina is attacking
this knight on d4 with the Queen and
with the bishop on d2 and also the
threat of Knight to f6 check is still
there so it's better to give up the
exchange then a piece a knight to c6 was
played and
Queen captures nb7 before night of six
check now threatening the rook on a
eight and the bishop on c7 so you can't
play rugby eight to gain a temple on the
Queen because the bishop is hanging we'd
have to play rook to c8 and now comes
Knight to f6 with check for King the
king and the rook King to d8 was played
and now not capturing the rook but there
is a much better move capturing the rook
is also winning for white but you know
you have to play the best move Knight
captures on d7 and this is now
completely lost for black you can't
really capture the night if you capture
simply Bishop captures and c6 you lose
another piece it's nothing for black
here capturing with the King go it's the
same after Bishop captures and c6 this
would check so even worse
so after Knight character son b7 Knight
captures on e5 was played Knight
captures on e5 rook captures on e5 and
now Rob H 2 e 1 and in this position
Alexander Hilario takeda sekai dos
Santos fear resigned the game as he has
done a piece it's pretty pointless to
continue this game whatever black plays
a white what doesn't even have to try
white is winning by force in many
variations so let's just show one for
example f6 defending the rook after rook
captures F captures and rook to f1 it's
it doesn't matter what white plays here
any move black plays for example a 6-row
to f8 Czech wins by force the rook has
to be captured and after Bishop to g5
check you have to give up the Queen or
you're getting checkmated so Queen to e7
is only move given up the Queen but this
is pretty much same as resigning but if
you play something like King to d7 then
Queen to c6 it's checkmate and if you
try something like King te 8 this is all
this also leads to force checkmate Queen
c6 check out King at 7 Queen f6 check a
King g8 Queen captures g6 check King h8
Queen h5 check King g7 Queen h6 check
now King geez GG 8 and our bishop does
come into play with tempo Bishop e5
check
Queen has the block and now for example
Bishop to f6 and
it's mate in one would ever black place
if he captures still Queen here on g7 is
checkmate if even if the Queen stays
there in g7 is checkmate because the
Queen is pinned so definitely definitely
an interesting game
I appreciate chest 24 for tweeting this
like I said I really couldn't resist
making a video on this game so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and what do you think happened here did
the Nino really crush Alexander that
hard or or are you one of those people
maybe who think that subconsciously
Alexander didn't want to sleep on the
couch tonight either way either way a
wonderful game in the birds opening and
the last chord variation so that's it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here once again I would like to
thank Chris tops McManus Felix clutter
and Donna lattice for contributions to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it I hope to see you all
tonight in the stream the stream starts
in some I think nine hours from the
point of making this video and yeah I
think all for watching and I will see
you soon